well hello there reject nation olivia's back with
me today thrilling because we cover avatar less or
better we covered all of it on our patreon watch
alongs and reaction highlights over there and
we just finished season two of legend of korra
as well and we've had this promise for a while
we're doing the last airbender movie now i am kind
of excited this is to see it ever heard nothing
but good things about it you excited i was excited
and then allergies let the allergies do the job
yeah it's rough it's not like we live together
and we can't just shoot this some other day it
has to be right now anyway guys want the full
length to watch along for this movie reaction
you could check us out on patreon become a
super sexy reject today oh we got a whole
bunch of other stuff there too if you don't want
to do that leave a like that would mean a lot
we only call the people who subscribe to your
patreon super sexy she watches the channel also
subscribe and click that notification bell because
we want to get notified when our reaction for some
other movie is up here and thanks to the
boys at prep for helping us edit this down
water
earth
i don't know what that one is dust the avatar was
the only person born amongst all the nations who
could master all four elements with the spirit's
guidance the avatar kept balance in the world
cool and then a hundred
years ago he just disappeared
book one are we gonna do all of them
that must be guitar a white girl
stop doing that stuff around me i always get wet
grade a acting hey hey just started already
thrilled about this move away from the cracks
let's see it
do not hit that sphere
hey it's kind of cool
they really are white huh very white
she kind of looks like uh buff of the
vampire slaver's younger sister oppa i mean
that's pretty cool he looks dead right now
but i'm sure once he actually flies yes i'll be
ecstatic we need to get him back to the village
what is this thing
he's trying to eat me
i ran away from home we got in a storm we
were forced under the water of the ocean
the vfx aren't bad no they're good
what if we end up loving this movie
i'm a little worried we're gonna love it
i mean acting is not great but there's
something wrong no please wait here
it feels like a 90s movie like braveheart
yeah like steven seagal's the siege
coincidence that we break him out of the ice light
shoots in the sky and now the fire
nation is here with their machines
dev patel zuko silka don't how'd you pronounce it
zuko zucco no no it's saka i know but i thought
bring me oh you're elderly
grandma damn they are so white
at least there's asian people
in the village who are you
what's your name i don't need to tell you anything
i'm taking you to my ship if you don't come
i'll burn down this village i'll go with
you boy everything's happening so quickly
this feels that way because they're
condensing a bunch of episodes they were
looking for someone old and they were looking
for someone with the same markings the boy had
we found that boy he's our responsibility
we should fight what would you do if they
try to take me away that kills them all
soccer's so serious in this movie i know
it's so cute oh that's so cool
where's your little stepped up on
what do you want with me my nephew wants
me to perform a little test on you iro
that's ira okay weird it only takes a
few moments and then you're free to go
would you mind if i put a few
things in front of you at the table
eero have we been saying it wrong this whole time
no we were saying it right he's hanging around
the fire nation doesn't wish to live by the
spirits that's why they are so frightened by
the existence of the avatar he will begin
to change hearts and it is in the heart
that all wars are one i think it's in the
weapons i think it's in the nuclear bombs
oh are they going to teach them
how to use all four elements
no they're running the experiments
auto inadvertently teach him
you are my prisoner really half-assed that scar
did it is truly an honor to be in your presence
don't even try to escape this is abortion
ah cool [__] make a little
circle ball little air ball
i didn't do the ball
don't move i mean he's got a lot he's gonna fly
thanks for bringing opera to me
the fire nation is up to something
i have to go back now we'll come with you
why i don't understand what's happening
it's not conflicting enough for them
aung flew us to his home he told us
how he left there in a storm on up why
can't they pronounce anyone's name right
cool aung air bended a sphere around them and ice
oh he couldn't remember anything after that what
is happening monkey atta's gonna try and jump
out and scare me at any moment he's the teacher
responsible for me boy i love the relationship
building we're getting between all three of them
is it okay if you tell me your name
the monks named me ang okay guys enough
oh my [__] god it's mom you're behind us
that does not look real we keep them as pets
weren't they extinct a long time ago exchange
no there must be thousands of them on this mound
your friends were monks i know where they are
right now didn't he say that would they land it
did she does she know it's been a hundred
years what'd you guys talk about when you run
i think you're in that ice for almost 100 years
firebender started a war what did they talk about
is a lot darker than i was expecting it to be yeah
it feels like when a youtuber
makes a serious gritty version
we've gotten no character
building from any of these
oh thank god i'm so worried i'm glad they're
able to pull him out of that dark hole
i commend the fire lords discipline
for example it seems i need to remind
prince zuko that during his banishment he is
an enemy of the fire it's an appropriate uncle
i was going to make a joke but decided
not to like a child wearing a costume
one day my father will take me back
and you will bow before me i'd be gay
look at that rubber sword
i don't know if it's called
it's so rubbery rubbery
oh my god are we gonna get uh his sister oh
that'd be great azula queen azula you mean
why is he standing like that i think it's
good to frame action scenes in a way where
you can't see a lot of the just keeping a
really tight shot he's like hunchback like
you know my grandma thinks because you're
an airbender that you could be the avatar
uh he was in ice for a hundred
years are you the avatar wrong
it's tough what is this no stay hidden if
they don't make toff blind i'd be very upset
it's got the green up that child
was being arrested for what
he was bending tiny stones
at us from behind a tree oh
she's a bender another one
katara
classic
i love how they reserved all the asian people for
just i was gonna say or the uh the fire nation
and they sent their machines huge machines made of
metal there's nothing we could do those who could
not bend were allowed to live in peace if we were
in prison i'm pretty sure they're just doing like
five minutes of each episode i i think that's what
it is yeah if the avatar had returned would that
mean anything to you the avatar is dead if he was
here he would protect us well and i'm the avatar
i ran away but i'm back i appeared to you all
ah
is he doing that how is he
doing that is it air better
earthbending's the coolest in the show in this
movie for sure don't be afraid it's my favorite
in the show too no air is the coolest in the show
but in this movie earth bending's the coolest
why is that one fire nation guy just
standing there waiting for his turn
look at all the fire nation guys not doing nothing
they just gave up they literally just left
i guess i'm fascinated because this could
have been a really cool movie done right
like they have everything here they took away
any tools related to bending you have the earth
why does momo sound like nosferatu
the fire nation took this scroll from a member
of your water tribe damn that's convenient i
need to tell you something what is it um i ran
away before they trained me to be the avatar i
don't know how to bend the other elements but
we saw you move that rock earlier they said i
could never have a normal life that i could never
have a family they said that's a sacrifice the
avatar always has to make okay so what what if we
found you teachers teachers to teach you bending
which element would you have to learn first and a
woman what if we found you a woman take my sister
they're just gonna wow what
exactly is the plot of this movie
if you're like fast forwarding through
you're like that's just happening they're
fast forwarding through the plot of the actual
show this is fascinating it's just like stuff
happens is this movie it really had the
potential to be something like decent
even with its wide watch you could have
the potential to be certainties yeah
that's right sherlock shocks the scroll
we have had was proving to be helpful
ong was practicing but for some reason he was
having trouble with water bending maybe because
it's moving so fast we moved from
town to town in the earth kingdom
we try to stay out of sight but soka became
concerned we were being followed he became
concerned why would you think you were
not big fella i don't understand this
the land of oz that's exactly what that
looks like we could bring down the northern
water tribe city we could show the world
the true strength of fire i am pleased
i'm going to say that after sex now oh um please
my son doesn't find this person first and he
turns out to be the avatar he would return as
a hero and for all purposes be your superior
well i suppose it's a race then what is this the
dad is kind of on his side in this show in this
movie i'll roll with it it's my whole experience
of this so far he spoke out of turn to a general
in defense of some of his friends who are going
to be sacrificed in a battle then principal was
sentenced to an agony key duel what is that how do
they pronounce anything right he would not fight
his father then his father mocked him and said i
should bring your sister up here to beat you yes
yes father burned his son to teach him
a lesson left him a very minor scar
very minor you can't even tell
looking at it directly on right now
he thinks if he goes to another spiritual place
he can get back to the spirit world i don't think
that's a good idea we started a rebellion try
to talk about it did you when uh ten minutes ago
we're just time jumping like every two months
every five minutes is every two months later
what has happened it's actually started
off like this might not be so bad
like there's so much happening in this one movie
this little kid worked out for
six months before doing this
damning super easy bailey and inconvenience
once that yapping woman ate next to him
it's been like six months for him you know
you gotta overcome your trauma this movie is
not good it's better than dragon ball evolution
these are all the avatars i like how
reincarnations of they're all not burnt
in the same exact areas yeah you will forgive
me won't you for what for luring you down here
okay poverty because of your absence
avatar oh yes finally my actions today
this is actually one of the most believable
parts of the movie is that someone's finally
like where the [__] have you been i know my life
he doesn't even seem to be dealing with being uh
she's like i've adjusted you must go to the
northern water tribe if they take that city
more will suffer and die as your airbenders have
you must go now you okay yes it's kind of boring
don't worry i'm not going to kill you i'm just
going to hurt you really really really bad
i think aesthetically some
of this shit's cool already
even if we hadn't seen this show i still
think this is really rushed this feels
like non-stop but it's because it's definitely
worse because i've seen the [__] yeah but no
i would still have the same complaints
i feel like so much is happening here
let's just keep skipping time and yet we have no
character development yeah what's going on here
i didn't know we had white guards
yeah that wig is wild
this is very convenient
for him that that was there
he's good at the action oh kinda bored do not
kill the avatar he will just be reborn again
why are you doing this who are you
that's a scary ass mask damn open the gates
let them out
i feel like a bunch of people
could have gotten the drop off
don't you have bows and arrows archers
right over here they wait so
many so many people are there
so many people could have gotten a job on it do it
whoa
why'd you wait for me to get
that far i don't understand
i mean that guy's really good with
the stick man he is really talented
at that it's really hard to do what he's doing
that's your fault what is this
you let him go like [__]
500 000 feet before launching an arrow to aha
i like how the action thinks it's cooler
than what it is yeah but now he's really
good with the stick toward the man probably
a competitive martial artist or something
i think we moved on to season two
season three the word that came down
is this person the soldiers
are calling the blue spirit yes
why'd they frame the father like
he's a mysterious figure we have
did he control fire i don't think they
know what their powers are in this movie
he's gone to seek out someone in
the northern water tribe where
they have lived beyond our reach and openly
practice water bending it's an abomination
oh it looks kind of creepy yeah the animals
have no personality start acting like dracula
this looks cool though it looks great
this is the north though isn't aren't they bad and
much decor it's the moon lady my brother and the
princess became friends right away thank you for
telling us all this we don't have time to show you
we don't have time to build really look at the
look that's all you're gonna get they're in
love now if we let too many of them into this
city their sheer numbers could overwhelm us
as many fires in this city should be put out as
possible in the alarm sounds we want to minimize
their benefit they all look the same there's no
boomi it's not booming presence is our inspiration
i'll do it that's me i'll be her
guard nothing will happen to her
they're in love oh did you have that feeling
this movie just skips over any and all character
development just you've you've seen that you've
seen the show right you just want us to reference
it right water teaches us acceptance your
emotions flow like water act impulsively that's
what i that's what i picked up no rational
or logical explanations for any emotion
see you got this your son
died in that siege didn't he
yes he did again i offer my condolences on your
nephew running to death in that terrible accident
i've loved spending these weeks with you weeks
my grandmother will ask you a lot of questions why
is your hair white young lady you look very odd
i would say to you grandmother my hair is
white because when i was born i was not awake
my mother and father could not get me to make
a sound or move i wasn't actually asking i was
making a joke dipped me into the sacred waters my
parents said that my hair turned white then and
life put into me that's
faster you didn't tell me that
she just did you didn't ask me only your
grandmother did talk to me about your grandma
i'm rooting for that zhao has no sacredness are
you sure you want to be here i don't want to be
i here not be allowed to live in peace until i
bring the avatar to my father is that not clear
to you they don't think you're dead go start a new
life god dude this cast has no chemistry it's it's
pretty rough they and like none of them feel like
at all from there what do you mean animated feels
like what none of them feel all for their animated
counterparts and they all just feel like flat
one-note versions of something i don't even know
what they are oh is this where they fall in love
oh these two especially have no cameras oh my god
the writing doesn't even try don't
know you wouldn't even know that
they end up together in the show because this
is so dull there's no life behind the story
some of these visual effects are phenomenal though
no i agree but this is so good fire nation is here
cora is a more interesting character than all
that says something maybe jesus sure i
actually think this will make me appreciate it
they're proud to have legend of korra or out
the window now congratulations congratulations
i'm trying not to keep comparing it to the show
but it's just as bad if you don't compare to the
it's worse to be compared but man
actually oh my god he found superman's later
i have to talk to the dragon spirit
he can help me defeat the fire nation
okay is there a spiritual place where i
can meditate you've been there for weeks
and you're just asking where you're gonna meditate
what the hell some of the great
monks can meditate for four days
we don't have that kind of time i should
have asked about this couple weeks ago
uh i love this moment in the show remember this
is my one of my favorite episodes i'll take you
and her hair is not white it's clearly a little
bit pink and lavender there but okay whatever
he's trying to meditate i love you fire lord son
you took him from our village that
was like two years ago this time
won't you cool down my name is katara and i'm the
only water bender left in the southern water what
why are you giving him this information seemed
like you were confessing something to him
like hey i'm trying to work with you
that was pretty believable
considering we've not seen her
progress at all hey we haven't seen anyone
true the water vendors get power from the moon
they will get stronger as the day comes to an end
general hero i've been keeping a secret
i would pronounce your name wrong hotel
i found a scroll which tells the
location of the ocean and moon spirits
to meet a spirit why why are they
telling everything to each other
they've successfully invaded
they had no measures to prevent
no issues at all actually did they say if they
got through the city walls well there you go
what is my makeup still into it zuko's
here in the city he took hong again
she delivers all and then i heard him say he
couldn't leave with that i think we can convince
him to be friends you are angry you must let this
go as the avatar you are not meant to hurt others
yeah i didn't pick up on any of that
i didn't realize he was struggling
with this emotion because i haven't
seen any of it so go do this now
this is like a b movie with a great production
boy zuko is so dumb in this
in this movie holy toledo
calm down you'll find it release the
extended cut to stop a character moment
water unleashed
are you okay dude this soccer guy's just
coasting through scene no job at all nothing
he's got a creepy ass face set up
boy when was this made this not good see where
they're going i'll go join the fight okay
do more of your practice form
choreography we are now the gods
it has begun
has he turned evil
it's a pretty cool shot looks like his hand's on
fire you can give your life back for the spirits
don't listen to him nothing i don't
understand how this movie doesn't get better
so it gets worse there are reasons
we have to find those reasons
if you haven't seen avatar you're
like who the [__] is this
why is he friends with them now
how can you understand you don't know what
will happen i believe that you know the
voice will leave my body and return to the
moon spirit oh not this character i love
so much my people are dying sokka those who
are in charge of others have a responsibility
it's time we show the fire nation that we believe
in our beliefs as much as they believe can we say
our vows like this yeah no emotion just
stoned me towards my mother i'll miss you
more than you know she's actually the best child
actor out of them but he is not good oh man
they're like get those look at them
that's why she had the
white hair they told us that
so they're just showing us in this
moment man sako was my favorite character
so the span of like 15 minutes
they killed the fish the moon was
turned red she died moon's back aang had a
mid-life crisis about killing people somehow
he cares about the spirits or something you know
who are these for it's for randos
i have no idea who they are
oh my god they should have murdered him
those are the four items he chose cool
we
he seemed to work so hard on all
this choreography this kid man
avatar state
man all that off-screen training really paid off
go fight the water stab the water
where's my big tadpole
where the [__] is my big tadpole they
thought that would be too goofy oh really yeah
really it was about the
friendship of the three of them
with each other look it's better than
dragon ball evolution aung and eero
now you bow you bow i love the fire nation people
what i guess this is the end of the journey
oh this could have been so powerful too this
moment but they just did not do martial arts
you must stop the avatar from mastering earth and
fire you must give us the time to get to that day
it's three years no problem this unspeakably
important task i'm putting in your hands
oh too bad we're never gonna
get hurt i do that damn
but also i'm glad because i feel like they
would have ruined her this explains a lot that
explains so much for me we
did it we did it oh my god
kathleen kennedy produced this you ruined
the last jedi star wars and now this
you just ruined everything they could have knocked
out like half a season in their post-credits
scenes it's so weird because at the beginning
it's like it you don't understand that they
are going like season by season you just assume
it's all going to be covered in this one movie
because they move so fast what are they gonna
do about bossing saying when we didn't get jet
this is the last movie the last airbender indeed
there's no there's no other one moving after
this one i'm excited for the netflix show i was
gonna say is it live action yeah fast what i do
oh there's just so much potential for this to
be so cool you know like it's always like i said
if they wanted to do like a live-action naruto
show i think it'd be so cool if it's well done
but boy it got worse as it was going along no yeah
just kevin is is slowly i'll talk about it let
me just i don't think there's a post if there is
we're not watching it all right i can't tell them
all right guys listen it's better than dragon
ball evolution so it gives a high recommendation
you did not sit through dragon ball evolution i
should not and i've never seen any of dragon ball
so it it doesn't matter it is that is that
was a really boring ass yeah that was like
wow this is atrocious and and this was at
least like it looked good at times and had a
kid who could do some good stick fighting had
a really good form so obsessed with that why
just because i know what it's like to be a little
kid in martial arts and i'm watching him like he's
actually really good at he's better than most
actors who they train to be martial artists
in movies and like he was believable in the in
the fighting and so i was appreciative of that
it's hard to find like a little kid who can has
he he had the surface cadence of aang you know
that hey i'm what's the word i'm looking for not
affable kind of laughable i didn't even think that
it was laughable they're all so boring i know
they're boring everyone's boring in this room
they're terribly boring like eggs sometimes
ang aong in here has no personality there's
no doubt at least while sometimes he could be
like kind of stoic it's because you're you know
his journey he's learning to be who he is after
being frozen for a hundred years here i'm just
like what the [__] is wrong with this one well
thanks thanks i remember aang being like kind of
funny and uh yeah he was like he had a really big
crush on cora katara and and uh he felt like a an
actual like little kid and and um there was a
depth to him because he was really pained by
the the the guilt he felt over abandoning
yeah everyone like everything in here but
but it's actually you know yeah a character
thing in the show it's actually part of the chat
and this show this movie that's because i i
did start thinking like i think they're just
skipping character beats and moving the plot
and the second they got to um uh where'd they
get to the southern water tribe the second
they got to the southern water and tribe and
and and then this is the very second the voice
over this pointless point this voiceover that's
clearly there just to speed things along uh
went uh and my brother fell and i got along
really well with the princess i'm like okay i
guess there's just that is it they just skip
fast character beats and just hop straight
to like we've moved this train going man we
got a lot of plot to cover here we're trying to
chat we don't we didn't want to cut anything out
they've traveled with him for how long on
oppa and didn't tell him that he'd been in
the thing for a hundred they didn't decipher
that while talking to him during their journey
well the show he he learns that when he's
on the boat in the first two episodes he's
like dealing he's having the crisis there and the
epiphany oppa is a character momo is a character
here they're just like pointless
animals well there's i mean like
the thing is we could spend all day comparing this
to the show when i think anyone who's watching she
already knows how [__] atrocious of a movie
this is there are moments it's just a bad movie
it's like a it's a bad movie if you watch our
reactions to avatar the last serving of the show
i have a lot of criticisms with yeah the show it
goes up and down yeah it goes up and down for me
but but there's a lot of like fantastic episodes
this ends on a strong note yeah it's way
even the worst episodes that i did like i would
watch a hundred times oh yeah this definitely
definitely like at the end of the
day we should have watched this first
you know what this is so bad but i i feel like if
even if i didn't watch the show i would put this
on and be bored out of my freaking mind there's
nothing to keep me interested in the characters
i don't care about any of the relationships it
it jumps around so much and the acting is almost
i don't want to say cartoony because i feel
like what we got on the show is better than
what we got here like it would have had more
personality if it was cartoony yeah it's just flat
it's it's really flat weird i don't like it at
all i mean no chemistry between any of the actors
which is which is so weird to me because i'm
like you guys had a show to pull from like the
actors and m night shyamalan directing
his actors there's a show to pull from
for the characters and and i'm like if you're at
least make it up with good acting and i'm like
how can you not even do that it was so like saka
was they butchered to me the one that's really
butchered is saka really i think zuko's destroyed
here i at least got what dev patel was going for
he was going to go for that like oh i'm in pain
and i'm i'm angst but no there's no there's no
threat no build up with his relationship with
his uncle and how important that is you get but
they don't really understand how tension filled
the relationship with this father because you
have that same with this father being like don't
heart my child but the soccer okay oh yeah the
[__] the father is actually no yeah i would
i would actually say i forget the father's name
firelord um he he's probably the most butchered
because he's he's destroyed he was like intense
and scary and and the way they built him up and
then when he had scenes you were just like this
guy has no soul like he is just the worst he's a
big baddie in the show you know he's the one who
hangs the big showdown with in the end and here
he's just like some like he's weak he seems weak
um he just he seems like a dude who's in
a royalty position but is ultimately weak
and uh but with soccer what really upset me is
like he's not funny a big part of saka is you know
he's got the boomerang it's so funny
with boomerang well he's a good strategist he's
a navigator and and he's what makes him really
likable is he's not one of the benders but you
see how how necessary he is and how funny he is
um and in here this guy's like just weirdly just
wide-eyed than serious the whole time like what
why couldn't you just make him funny just make him
funny what sorry about that just try to make him a
little funny and they didn't feel like brother
and sister katara i mean they're all ruined
they're all when you compare them to this [__]
they're all they're all ruined they're all ruined
and um i'm glad that i was able to i'm glad that
we waited a little bit after watching avatar
because like we like korra the second season's a
little weak but uh but the the but the the if we
had to watch this right after avatar i think this
would have been just a nightmare etcetera i think
yeah but this at least allowed us some space
to like objectively watch it without um
without it being like because yeah in the first 10
minutes i was going oh [__] i'm worried though
i'm gonna like just i was a little a little
nervous then like this isn't actually as terrible
as i thought everyone said usually it was pretty
and yeah you're like getting into the world but as
it goes off it has a bit of that wonder to it and
then and they're just getting adjusted and then it
just it literally just slowly yet the movies is
doing so much but it is slowly descending into
just the worst mess where by the time i'm like
why are we here at the southern water tribe and
how did like it doesn't feel like we built
up to this this battle at all and and you're
you're you're they just skip a lot of scenes
start and just like they cut away from them
they just like cut away from them when
they start or they narrate the rest of this
there's no real beginning middle and end to
things it's just like [__] happens that's
that's the definition of this movie is stuff
happens and then we get here because then you
think about all you've covered from aang waking up
to getting kidnapped to escaping to then freeing
phil earthbending villages like what the hell is
going on spanning that getting captured again um
zuko and then like they shoved so much in and
it it just doesn't flow the blue spirit they
shoved that in and that goes for a while in the
show because you i mean you know it doesn't go
but like it's built up here it's just like oh
you know they know who it is immediately it's
just well it's a co it's a conflict where you're
like is zuko gonna be good or bad you know is is
this izuko doing this because he's like zuko was
someone who like i would go back and forth between
liking and just absolutely hating and yeah and
then by the third season i remember i called them
so yeah i mean but you know what actually i'm
really mad that they butchered that ending
fight because in the first season
it is like this on the podcast okay
just wait for it to turn off
sorry sweet wit boy i'm tired and tired
[__] hungry i thought bolt for you thanks
gotta be over the knee so too
man
why's it not turning off because it just turned on
i don't know why it just turned on because it's
boiling here it's the room jesus christ okay the
lack of air here the carpet that blows heat can't
wait to move what do you think i'm always like
dirty to see you always tell you all right so go
take it from like if you were set by the fight
yeah so i'm really upset the more i think about
it how that fight went at the end because in
the finale of the first season that is so visually
stunning i remember not really being into the show
up until the last few episodes and that was what
i was like super into because i thought visually
was that season one i think it was okay because
oh yeah season two is when it ends with with zuko
patricia zuko betraying uh katara yeah yeah yeah
so since at the season one i remember that's when
it really gripped me because i was like oh they're
doing a real combination of the spirit world
and this visually it was just so beautiful and
and that was the one moment i remember being
okay i really do like this show and they [__]
just ruined a hair and you don't get any of that
beautiful visual spirit world mending with egg
and or ogg or whatever you want to call it here
the more you think about it come here come
here baby come here tomorrow we hated this
furiosa very mad at it very bad angry
anyway yeah movie's terrible everyone's like
you can literally sum it up with the action
is mediocre and um it's it's rush they try jam
packing too much and every character is flat
and then if you compare the characters to the
show that's even worse like like i like i'm not
even saying you need to do the show it's just do
something interesting if you're going to change
but they don't it's so bizarre because they don't
change the characters they just go what are some
traits they have let's just remove all them and
just give them this one and just move with that
like iro is was awesome in the show man and here
here i thought they might do something interesting
with him like he you know ira is like like a like
your chubby uncle who appears lazy at first but oh
no he's actually a skilled dude and this guy looks
like remember that they're kind of yoga yeah yeah
yeah that's like a big deal when he got all buffed
because they're like oh [__] i was in shape
um but here he this dude seems like the kind of
like yoga teacher who would bang the students
you know like that the hot daddy
like oh i got daddy and she got him
and he calls him uncle but but you never get
the sense of the uncle and the dad having like
there's a tension between them as brothers you
know there's so much missing variables here
what's wrong is awake i'm good we're just
talking come here buddy watch it awake and um
and uh i don't know it's just so easy like
literally it's just it's and it's just boring
too it's a boring movie it's it's really
boring and that's the worst thing you can
do like there's no life in this movie at least
i can please give us comedy i can always settle
for it's bad but it's so fun like i could at
least settle for that but when once you reach
boring territory then i'm like ah dammit movie
why'd you have to go boring on me because
yeah that's it's not even because it it
doesn't it it doesn't quite it just fall
it reads flat instead of super cheesy you
know and if you just went like super cheesy
that would have been enough just just at
least commit to being over the top cheesy
but didn't do that look at him he just laid
there i know i'm so happy that's quiet he's
just like they didn't come in here like what's he
doing in here right now he just that's all that's
cause i i used a whole bottle of quiet moment
spray all over this house i've had a phantom sh
everywhere look at him i got there the ac system
look how tired he is he is so sleepy he's so tired
all right oh let's see we don't need to give
you any pills we just need to spray that [__]
anyway i feel like we can go scene by scene and
talk about how this was butchered especially
compared to the show but it's really easy to sum
it up this is not a good movie and everything
except some of the technical stuff like some
of the visual effects some of the music is good
and uh yeah that's fine but none of that ever
compensates for the actual scenes there's no it's
void of emotion the actual story's missing
from here it's just yeah and and i wonder
uh what makes me so curious
is if you've never seen avatar
like what is the what is this movie to you
would you watch this i i i can't imagine
i feel like people might be a little confused at
certain moments of just keeping up with a bunch of
bored they're bored like like okay i'm just you're
titling things and saying where you are but i
don't know what this is like i don't know what's
happening really you know like even for me i'm
like wait what's the plot of this movie is i had
to remind myself of the show of oh yeah he needs
to like become gather learn the at the element
it's just so it's so disjointed and so not focused
it is all over the place and i don't want to
be wrong in this but i think i'm right in the
first season the whole reason why the fire
nation wanted to get rid of the moon spirit
was because their powers were weakened during the
moons during that full moon i thought i thought
that's the whole reason that's not even mentioned
here it's just like we don't like the moon spirit
stab the fish well they they've it's because
the water benders are stronger when they have
the moon for the moon so they were like let's
eliminate the moon yeah but the water benders
lose all their powers when the moon and here
when it was played up in the show i thought that
the fire nation specifically lost they were not
able to use their power during certain moments
or is that social's comment i don't remember
that's susan's comment that's the comment
i thought they're supposed to be
more powerful during the comic
but the comet's not into play here at all i know
it's sweater
yeah why did that fall on me i don't know
it's missing development clearly i don't know
how many times when i say that it's just not good
i ca i guess it's it's funny we see dragon ball is
one of those movies where you're like you clearly
didn't even watch the show like that's so it's
so obvious you didn't watch the show and what's
odd to me is like i feel like you guys watch
the show because this is all from the show so
and there are looks that are directly pulling from
the show and i just don't understand how no one
stepped in to be like how do you not do
you realize what you're skipping over here
like do you know what this is
to me and you said it perfectly
i told you about that client i would work
with who would love to listen to me read
descriptions of movies from wikipedia yeah and i
would just read the plot description that's what
this entire movie is it's like if you just took
out all the personality and character and just
plot description from wikipedia if you had someone
reading and you're in your mind visualizing what's
happening it would be this that's what
this movie is a big part of of the show
is with aang is wondering is him struggling to
develop all his abilities especially with fire
and and it's and it's like is he gonna be ready
in time for when the moment comes you know when
he really has to when he has to fight the fire
lord and here it's like he's got a little bit
of like uh it's like he's got the water down but
he's like i'm a little scared like that's what
it is he's like oh my god i'm a little trouble
i got a little slight bit of trauma here this
is i don't want to deal with it but for the most
part he's got like a great handle on everything so
it never feels like anything's at stake there's
like zero stakes in this fight a certain point he
has this whole weight of him being the only
one who could save the world on him and you
feel that in the show in here it's just blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah yeah
what is happening yeah this is so this is so not
focused and and there's and the bottom line is you
you can't tell a season's worth the television
in two hours there's not even two hours and
you can't tell season with television two hours
you can't tell you can't tell us he's worth the
television three hours like you should have told
this much story you just shouldn't have done this
much plain and simple you shouldn't have done all
this you know you just can't introduce a bunch of
plots without it's like you got to focus on
something something has to be the focus and
and bottom line is like you just it usually
doesn't work to develop a show into a movie
nine times out of ten especially with like
things like that are so rich and lower yeah
and everything because then you feel like the
need to i gotta include some of this like earth
betting was so unimportant to this story you
could have removed it it was so unnecessary
that whole scene was yeah the whole scene wasn't
necessary so yeah i don't know how to get the
point i guess and there are moments where the fire
people are literally just standing in the back
waiting their turn to fight i'll peel lost okay oh
yeah fire nation doesn't seem like a threat at all
who's next oh my turn to go up there i'm like
what is happening it's so bad all right guys
i want to talk about this i'm so blind follow
some picture up for all the other things that
we like to cover but thanks for being here
at least we finally watch this [__] bye